hi baby boy talking to the fishies you
and me son we're different we're special
we're connected to the land and the sea
I can't wait to introduce you to all the
majestic creatures on our planet and
show you how awesome this world can
be yeah you and
me I'm going to kill
[Music]
Aquaman even if I have to make a deal
with the devil to do
it free me from my prison and all my
power will be yours the key to this
prison is the Royal bloodline
itself he needs us we're The End Of The
Bloodline no we're
not
yeah Mana took
Junior
he must be
[Music]
stopped I'm coming for
you destroy everything he holds
dear you want
bloody come
get Aquaman and the Lost Kingdom tickets
on sale nowo PG-13 only in theat
December 22nd